hello and welcome to the open web master
hurry not on with white no name okay
yeah I went for a form let's get some
variety in the Russell Nemo quite a good
scoring it's very not a three against 13
13 wins one loss okay plays a funky
reply 95 this is not particularly great
but it's also yeah not something that
wide will win against a couple of moose
but why should definitely have a nice
position we'll see what happens um what
am I doing here be 3d or just you for
let's just play do you form keep it
simple I to e4 wait that should run it
shouldn't stumble into night f4 that's
not something that I'd like to see ok
hmm maybe I should do something
something quick here
that is not so much to take on age seven
even though in some cases I might be
able to do it but I'm more taking about
94 m and possibilities to get the Queen
over to g3 really wow and there really
is because of Queen f3 twin f3 okay
maybe just e6 ok ok ok point taken so
I'm going to swing over here for
possible 93 or was just 94 next title g5
is a very annoying piece
Jim not quite sure what is what you
should play
yeah that's I mean I understand but it's
also going to be risky and so yeah even
even taking on these six taking on e
cigs this kind of kind of interesting
takes on d6 Bishop to 696 FTX Europe
chicks is 6mm that's very close to
working maybe it just just me just does
work it's very close at least when I'm
kind of worried about us i have no
development 96 takes root chicks Oh is
he holding this with some Bishop e7 it
might have my team might be that he
holds that
okay I'm going for this I mean this is a
gutting I'm getting short short on time
a little bit him yeah my attention was
the night of seven but I i simply forgot
about route 66 I even though it might
not be the end of the world King takes
Queen g6 okay maybe this is actually not
so clear yeah here 95 should be or we
can actually castle can castle
huh that's not good I completely forgot
that you can cast okay okay
yeah I rookie five doesn't work
unfortunately i can just six also leads
nowhere okay i need to play some kind of
move I was ashamed there was a
completely winning position or I don't
know I had looked like black was on the
verge of exploding them hey I'm wrong
but it looked it looked decidedly wrong
what black did here on many live money
so let's see
still not super easy I guess even though
I'm I definitely have lot just reviewed
it what he did definitely not mean if he
takes now 96 looks I cannot go them okay
let's take your first q into this one
whatever key position if you take that I
wonder where I actually go to a seven or
where now it's a backline mid stupid
check what a stupid game ah really hate
I hate reason really hate reduce this
the position was completely completely
over somehow let's check like night
chicks ki computer doesn't give a win so
okay I'm was a bit too optimistic when I
find it hard to believe that there
shouldn't be some kind of advantage him
with black king on the ADA posted to the
rook and so on so okay I took with this
night h7s it's a simple alternative okay
this is what the engine wants to do it
just once to wants to grab this pawn
yeah this is very good of course and
simple very simple you just you're just
a pawn up basically black has more more
development better development but thing
is let's say here and I'm just letting
him take on c3 this will open up the
bishop AI tremendously okay so that was
a way to a pretty big advantage but
still have a hard time to believe that
blacks should survive this
but it seems he does yeah yeah I'm don't
have it I don't have a great
continuation a forum night afore is
actually playable my comp comp fights no
advantage for white it is still kind of
murky yeah but it's not it's not chat
not great or anything this is what the
engine is giving it's quite funny why do
I deserve look down but it's only gives
minus one got three pawns yeah so there
the key to punish blacks opening here is
probably somewhere somewhere here Queen
g3 I felt should be okay now now this is
six again night h7s is stronger
yeah I was also thinking about this this
but this is I mean this is just check
not completed working like here you can
castle long I saw that line and black
it's black is holding on now I probably
have to play night XO yeah he has to
take a we get this we get this position
and yet it is pretty convincing actually
if I play what what happens if i play
that in a very simple manner just
prevent this I ok yes this this is 94
and it's important I hope that loaded
that's probably too passer a three years
too passive maybe maybe if I guess just
just retreat here and allow Him this
this kind of thing let's say I go here
now okay it's also no it's not super
super clear if why this man is hanging
on you saying how in the position is not
great but he's he's not lost or anything
maybe some other square like this we
cannot take because of this
yeah this is better for why but he still
he still continues to fight yeah so I
over estimated that during the game
white is better but it's not not like
black is falling apart which I was kind
of expecting now okay if night night
takes f7 was not working what i would
add what it did here I was originally
actually thinking I could take here but
he can just casts a long they decide him
but counseling long as just saving the
day for black was just a piece of yeah i
misplayed that was a it was a nice
position not a winning position but a
very nice one but I screwed up okay well
thanks for watching